僕去年頭から大量の花粉をかぶったんですよ
なんかショック療法で風邪を治すために
これ本当にあぶないんですよ
下手すればアナフィキラシー症候群で
死ぬかもしれないんですけど
なんか今年から花粉症が
ほぼ治りました
はじめしゃちょーです。
まじで真似しちゃダメだよ
花粉症がかなり楽
あれが効いたのか知らないですけど
今年は全然いけそうです
みなさんはiPhoneケースどんなの使ってますか？
おいらこうゆうの使ってます
めっちゃシンプルなの使ってるんですよこれ
角が何かくにゃくにゃしてて
落ちても
スマホは傷付かないような造りになってて
投げても一回も画面割れたことないんで
このケースでずっと僕は満足してたんですけど
プイいいいいいいいいい
俺は見つけてしまった
史上最強のiPhoneケースを
アップバンクさんで買いました
この俺が普通のiPhoneケースを紹介するわけないっしょ？
まじであの～
ネットで見た瞬間これだと思って
すぐ買っちゃったんですけど
あー！
あ！あ！あ！
あ、あ、
マックスだ
マックス～！
はーい
むらいさんありがとうございます
初めてアップバンクで商品買ったよ
あー！
マックスだ！
マックス～！
はい
宣伝しといてあげよう
これです
こちらどうですか
これiPhone用の
ゲームコントローラーらしいです
何かね持ち手みたいなiPhoneケースは
見たことあるんですけど
これもうその物ですからね
どうやって使うんだろう
そもそもさ
あ、そもそもiPhoneってさ
たったった
iPhone
あ
うん
そもそもiPhoneってタッチするのが普通だからさ
コントローラーとかでそのボタンを付けた時点で
使えるかどうかっていう問題点もある
そこちょっと気になるところなんですけど
ちょっと早速開けてみましょう
プイいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいい